foreign
[Music]
or the cannibal let's discuss this in
depth in this video
firstly who or what is vermouth well he
was a male dragon that was also known as
the bronze Fury and was formerly written
by King jehairus Targaryen vamatha was
born around 30 years after aegon's
conquest and was described as a golden
dragon with huge tan wings
only Valerian the black dread and the
sheer Dragon vegar were larger than
vermouth and by the year 48 AC he was
claimed For the First Time The Dragon
was about a century old at the time of
the dance of the Dragons he was a
companion of another large Dragon called
Silverwing vomitar was probably one of
the most powerful if not the most
powerful of all the dragons by the time
of the dance
on the other Corner who is the cannibal
during the dance of the Dragons the
cannibal was a wild Dragon who dwelt on
Dragonstone the small folk dubbed him
the cannibal because he practiced
cannibalism eating undeceased dragons
newborn dragons and even dragon eggs
along with sheep's Tila and Greg hoes he
was one of the three dragons that were
wild entirely while who lived on
Dragonstone the Cannibal's precise age
was yet to be determined the wild Dragon
Chief Steelers claimed to have hatched
while the Old King joharis was young
that as early in joharis the first rule
the cannibal is said to be even older
and the eldest and the biggest of the
three wild dragons making him older than
sheep's Tila and even older than Vega or
maybe as old as valerion
so is that Dragon the cannibal of
vermuthor so in episode 10 demon after
affirming the dragons that the blacks
have in their cam also said that
Dragonstone had two other large dragons
that could be claimed referring to
varmathar and Silverwing but at the same
time saying that there were three other
wild dragons that could possibly be
ridden and later he went to sing to this
large Dragon who was in that dark pit
the dragon rose up spewed a deadly flame
from his mouth into the air until now
with that in mind let's assess the
points that would tell us the identity
of this deadly and magnificent Beast
so firstly the dragon didn't attack
Damon after hearing the song that was
sung in High Valyrian meaning that this
Dragon was accustomed to people being in
his presence maybe even Dragon Tamers
and dragon Riders but at the same time
we can also say that the cannibal being
a dragon would have had a certain
tolerance to targaryens as they were
also Dragon Blood
we can see that the dragon was clearly a
very large specimen but that in itself
would give points to both vermethor and
the cannibal as they were two of the
largest dragons in Dragonstone so that
would get us nowhere exactly but we can
see that that dark cave the dragon was
in was in fact a dragon Pit and the wild
dragons were set to dwell in other areas
uninhabited by people so that's another
point for Verma Thor just to be sure we
have to take a glance at what has been
said in the books prior to the dance of
the Dragons would be Dragon Tamers have
made attempts to ride the cannibal a
dozen times and his lair was littered
with their bones even when a man called
Silver Dennis tried to tame another wild
Dragon called sheep's tailor the
cannibal took notice of the people there
and descended on them devouring them all
so the cannibal had a taste for blood
for human blood and if it was him then
Damon would be a snack by now therefore
with 99 certainty we can say that this
was the Bronze Theory Verma Thor
now we can start estimating the size of
vermouth and assess how big he was
compared to Vega and the others
so from looking at the different scenes
we can say that this Dragon was way
bigger than either character's or Cyrax
even bigger than melees as his jaw says
alone was more terrifyingly bigger than
the jaw of melees in the scene of her in
front of the greens during aegon's
coronation
by superficial examination we can say
that this Dragon had a head size of more
than 12 to 13 feet long twice the size
of Damon targaryen's height when
converted to length which we can
extrapolate
vermatoch we have a body length of
around 200 feet or 60 meters taking into
consideration that he has a similar head
to body ratio as most other dragons well
except for caraxis which was a deformed
bees and had a serpentine snake-like
body
therefore vomitar would be around 50
feet shorter than vegar but also 50 feet
longer than melees somewhere in the
middle he is in fact the third largest
dragon in that world so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support subscribe and
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel till
the next one take care fam